[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 pour cette
nouvelle émission nous sommes le jeudi
20 octobre voici le programme le projet
voisin 2035 se poursuit l'association
sens civique en partenariat avec la
Ville le planche de pique plusieurs mois
sur le futur de voisin le Bretonneux
l'enquête citoyenne s'est terminée le 30
septembre alors quels sont les retombées
nous ferons le point avec la mère de la
commune Alexandra Rosetti on reviendra
également dans cette émission sur le
mois de sensibilisation au cancer du
sein octobre rose à Mantes-la-Jolie le
centre médico-social du lac organisé des
ateliers pour soulager les femmes
notamment grâce à la socio-esthétique
mais alors qu'est-ce que c'est Raiponce
tout à l'heure et puis à l'approche des
vacances de la Toussaint nous vous
présenterons nos idées de sortie dans
les Yvelines Halloween à France
Miniature lumière sauvage dans les
jardins du château de Thoiry mais aussi
jeux de piste et cours de cuisine le
programme en deuxième partie de
l'émission
et avec moi en plateau Alexandra Rosetti
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la mère de la
commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux et vous
allez nous parler du projet voisin 2035
alors c'est pas trop compliqué de se
projeter 15 ans 15 ans après aussi
forcément mais c'est justement
l'occasion de rêver un peu de rêver sa
ville dans 15 ans donc c'est vrai que le
temps peut paraître un peu long mais le
voisin enfin les communes de demain
elles se préparent aujourd'hui et les
habitants qui ont été habités à inviter
à arriver on
a eu de jolis rêves et donc on en
parlera dans quelques instants autour du
plateau Grégory bonsoir vous allez nous
parler des actualités du jour alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots brièvement peut-être
sur piste puisque après les Mondiaux les
Mondiaux de Para cyclisme ont débuté
aujourd'hui il y a des Français à suivre
sur ces quatre jours de compétition
Vélodrome
Nicolas bonsoir bonsoir vous vous allez
nous parler d'une créatrice yves-ninoise
effectivement on va prendre la direction
du pays où Danais à côté de Houdan il y
a la commune de Richebourg et bien
là-bas il y a Mélissa assez bien qui est
une créatrice de mode éco-responsable et
enfin Gabriel bonsoir vous allez nous
parler des idées de sortie plutôt pour
les vacances de la Toussaint est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire un petit teasing
oui alors je vous ai sélectionné des
choses très variées on parlera de
cuisine de musées mais aussi d'Halloween
bien évidemment pour les vacances de la
Toussaint et bien vous le voyez le
programme est très chargé ce soir mais
avant de parler de tout ça je vous
propose qu'on fasse un petit point sur
la météo
[Musique]
prévoyez quelques averses demain matin
du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie et de
Versailles à Houdan et à Rambouillet
vous devriez avoir un temps sec avec de
belles éclaircies au niveau des
températures il fera toujours très doux
avec 16 degrés en moyenne pour vendredi
après-midi le soleil sera bien présent
sur toutes les Yvelines avec des
températures très agréables il fera 20
degrés à Houdan Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et 19 degrés à Rambouillet
et ce vendredi 21 octobre nous fêterons
les Céline alors nous n'oublierons pas
notre cher Céline Charles on lui
souhaitera bien sûr sa fête demain
et le point maintenant sur l'actualité
du jour
[Musique]
et on commence par cette information la
France a procédé au rapatriement de
plusieurs personnes jusque-là détenues
dans les comptes de prisonniers
djihadistes honores de la série très
précisément 15 femmes et 40 enfants qui
sont arrivés dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi à la base de Villacoublay dans les
Yvelines ces femmes font partie des
françaises qui s'étaient rendus
volontairement aux Oignies raccouriennes
et qui ont été capturés au moment de la
chute de l'État islamique le ministère
des Affaires étrangères indique que les
mineurs ont été remis au service chargé
de l'aide à l'enfance et feront l'objet
d'un suivi médico-social l'image du jour
à présent direction le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
après les Mondiaux de pistes de cyclisme
surpiste sont les championnats du monde
de paracyclisme sur piste qui ont
démarré ce jeudi ce soir d'ailleurs la
ministre des Sports Amélie ou des
accastéra et sur place 39 délégations
230 athlètes qui se disputent les à 61
titres décernés sur l'événement c'est
jusqu'à dimanche et les Français ont
déjà brillé sur cette première journée
Alexandre léoté et Marie Patouillet ont
battu le record du monde sur 200 mètres
lancés en catégorie C5 par exemple Marie
patouillait double médaillée de bronze
Jeux paralympiques de Tokyo réalise un
chrono de 11 secondes 605 c'est la
Néerlandaise Caroline groot qui détenait
jusque là le record et pour encourager
les Bleus l'entrée et gratuites et vous
pouvez réserver vos billets en envoyant
un mail à l'adresse suivante à point
pirette@andysport.org en somme envoyer
un miel un mail à Pierrette pour avoir
des des billets sur sur ces Mondiaux 98
Grégory c'est le chiffre du jour
pourquoi oui 98 millions d'euros c'est
l'investi l'investissement du
département des Yvelines pour le futur
campus de l'innovation mine Paris PSL là
à cause de la première pierre de ce
programme de 14000 m² a eu lieu ce matin
à Versailles Satory c'est ici que fin
2024 trois laboratoires de pointe de
l'École des Mines s'implanterons ils
accueillons 750 personnes dont 300
chercheurs et c'est une nouvelle étape
dans le projet du plateau de Satory
intégré on le rappelle à Paris Saclay ou
un nouveau quartier est en construction
et où la 2018 doit s'arrêter à l'horizon
2030 écoutez ces interviews
les Yvelines c'est aujourd'hui un
territoire où la recherche est
développement ce qui fait la richesse
d'un pays c'est dans les Yvelines que il
y a le plus de pépites et ce laboratoire
c'est laboratoire ces trois laboratoires
des mines vont venir nourrir ses pépites
et c'est pourquoi le département a fait
cet effort très très important nous
avons trois laboratoires qui se
regroupent dans des domaines qui
touchent la transition énergétique et
les matériaux pour la transition
énergétique et également tout ce qui est
robotique véhicules autonome nous sommes
effectivement au cœur de la transition
énergétique et de la transition
environnementale
et la pénurie de carburant toujours
d'actualité même si ça s'essouffle un
petit peu
ça Gonfreville en Seine-Maritime des
salariés de Feyzin seul autre site de
Total énergie encore en grève dans le
Rhône ont été réquisitionnés mais la
situation reste tendue dans 30% des
stations services franciliennes qui sont
en pénurie et d'au moins un carburant
alors s'il vous reste un peu d'essence
dans le réservoir peut-être vous
apprêtez-vous à prendre la route demain
soir pour le début des vacances de la
Toussaint regardez vendredi Bison Futé
voit orange dans le sens des départs en
Île-de-France il est conseillé et
d'éviter de quitter la région entre 14h
et 21h la couleur reste à l'orange pour
les départs samedi également pour ne pas
vous retrouver dans les bouchons
prévoyez de partir avant 9 heures sévère
dimanche dans les deux sens
merci beaucoup Grégory pour toutes ces
informations et si vous vous voyez une
information ou quelque chose qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le dire en utilisant le hashtag sur
Twitter 7 news
[Musique]
et on en parlait il y a quelques
instants le projet voisin 2035 alors
Alexandra Rosetti est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu mieux ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce projet
alors il est né de l'idée d'une
association qui s'appelle science
civique qui elle-même est né au moment
du débat du grand débat national c'est
elle qui avait animé enfin ce sont des
membres de cette association qui est
vanimer le grand débat voisin et puis on
s'est rendu compte de l'appétence des
habitants à discuter et à débattre donc
cette association s'est créée et donc un
de ces objets justement et ben c'est de
de réunir les citoyens sur différents
thèmes et de faire évoluer les villes
enfin en tout cas nous donner des idées
donc ils nous ont proposé de lancer une
grande consultation appelez voisins 2035
et ils ont fait un travail vraiment très
très important ils ont fait des ateliers
ils ont fait des visites exploratoires
ils ont mis en place une appli avec 50
ans en Yvelines d'ailleurs pour créer
une cartographie interactive où les gens
pouvaient se promener et mettre leurs
remarques là où là où il se promenait et
puis ça s'est terminé par un grand
sondage où il y a eu 450 réponses et
bien sûr la ville a été partenaire parce
qu'on les a accompagnés déjà d'un point
de vue financier parce qu'on leur a
permis de d'embaucher une apprentie qui
les a aidés et puis également on a
procédé avec eux un tirage au sort dans
les listes électorales donc on a tiré
900 personnes au sort pour les invités à
participer à tous ces ateliers et ses
marches ce qui n'était pas exclusif bien
sûr de tous les habitants qui avaient
envie d'y venir et donc oui vous avez
mis en place une enquête citoyenne du 15
juillet au 30 septembre vous avez fait
le compte-rendu hier soir qu'est-ce
qu'il en est ressorti de cette enquête
alors c'est c'est l'association qui a
mené ça bien sûr donc hier soir c'était
le rendu en fait de tout le travail
qu'ils ont effectué pendant presque un
an et
différentes thématiques ça peut être des
thématiques autour des déplacements je
crois que c'est des sujets qui nous
intéressent tous évidemment que ce soit
dans les déplacements courts c'est à
dire comment améliorer les déplacements
piétons et cyclables dans la commune
mais également entre les communes et
puis comment améliorer les déplacements
par exemple nous on se projette sur
cette ligne 18 qui va être aux portes de
voisins donc avec l'envie d'avoir de
créer des liens évidemment avec cette
gare il y a également tout ce qui
concerne la ville inclusive comment
comment est-ce qu'on vit ensemble et
comment on fait les choses ensemble avec
l'idée par exemple d'une résidence
intergénérationnelle bon ça tombe bien
puisque on est en train d'en construire
une donc c'est plutôt
on va tous un peu dans le même sens de
toute façon et donc voilà on a parlé
rénovations énergétiques aussi puisque
les habitants sont intéressés pour leur
pour leur propre habitation
environnement voilà tous ces sujets qui
qui ont fait sont classiques mais qui
ont donné lieu à des envies des idées et
qui vont donner lieu maintenant qu'on a
fait la restitution hier et les
habitants il y avait une centaine de
personnes ont un nouveau travail
ensemble et ça va donner lieu à un récit
voilà c'est l'idée c'est d'avoir un
récit commun sur l'avenir de notre
commune
des dernières municipales en 2020 on
parlait beaucoup de démocratie
participative aujourd'hui pour
administrer une ville on peut pas faire
100 sans la vie des habitants on est
obligé de les associer dans les projets
menés dans une ville oui alors c'est
très important d'ailleurs un groupe hier
soir qui a travaillé sur le sujet de la
démocratie participative disait il faut
que ce soit gagnant-gagnant et je trouve
que c'est une très belle expression nous
on a tout à gagner bien sûr à travailler
avec les habitants et les associés et
eux ils ont tout à gagner à comprendre
et à nous aider à faire évoluer certains
projets ça ne veut pas dire qu'au bout
du compte ce sont quand même bien les
élus qui ont été élus pour ça et qui
doivent prendre les décisions mais elles
doivent être éclairées par la vie des
citoyens
Nicolas vous avez une question par
rapport à la suite de la question de
Grégory on parle beaucoup justement de
démocratie participative mais la
principale critique faite à la
démocratie participative c'est que les
citoyens de s'en saisissent pas
forcément et finalement vous proposer
des systèmes des dispositifs de
démocratie participative mais il y a
très peu de participation par rapport à
la totalité de la population est-ce que
finalement dans le test que vous avez
fait l'expérience que vous avez fait
avec voisin 2035 c'est plutôt positif en
terme d'expérience participative alors
on était un peu déçu par exemple par
rapport au tirage au sort parce que 900
personnes tirées au sort et peut-être
une centaine qui comment qui répond qui
s'intéresse donc c'est quand même assez
peu il y a vraiment fallu aller chercher
les gens et on a pourtant mis des on a
mis des affiches dans la ville on a aidé
la l'association à communiquer donc il y
a le phénomène un peu les ce qu'on
appelle les ce que l'association appelle
les TLM toujours les mêmes voilà donc
c'est des personnes qui sont investies
dans leur commune soit dans les conseils
de quartier soit dans les dans le milieu
associatif et donc l'idée c'était
d'aller chercher des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de participer et dans les
freins qui sont évoqués alors un frein
est lié mais à mon avis c'est quelque
chose d'un petit peu plus même un peu
national c'est-à-dire à quoi ça sert de
participer parce que toute façon les
élus ils sont partent pas de ce qu'on
dit c'est une vision des choses et puis
il y a aussi évoqué le manque de temps
voilà parce qu'on travaille parce que
quand on rentre chez soi on n'est pas
forcément envie de repartir à des
réunions voilà donc tous ces sujets
qu'on connaît bien donc c'est pas facile
d'aller chercher des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de participer et c'était un
peu le but de ce tirage au sort et alors
en quelques mots rapidement parce que le
temps nous manque quelle est la suite de
ce projet quelle est la suite du
calendrier alors maintenant il va
falloir que ils vont nous rendre le
récit qu'on va faire partager au vif 6
mois bien entendu et puis après je pense
qu'on va on va s'emparer de ces quelques
sujets donc certains vont pouvoir être
inscrits dans le marbre dans par exemple
un prochain pays un prochain plan local
d'urbanisme si ça concerne l'urbanisme
et puis nous ça va nous permettre de de
réajuster peut-être notre notre
programme en fonction des des souhaits
des des habitants alors il y a un
souhait j'en profite je profite de
l'antenne pour lancer il y a un souhait
qui ressort beaucoup à voisin depuis
très longtemps c'est d'avoir un marché
et donc ça va être chose faite à partir
de 5 novembre nous ont un marché sur le
parking de la poste et tous les samedis
matin j'en profite pour faire ma petite
page de publicité mais voyons on va tous
dans le même sens l'envie d'avoir un
lieu convivial où on peut se retrouver
tout en faisant ses cours c'est voilà et
bien merci Alexandra Rosetti d'être venu
en plateau pour nous en parler je
rappelle que vous êtes la mère de la
commune de Voisins le bretonneux on va
parler d'une technique de soins peu
connue maintenant la socio-esthétique
dans le cadre du Mois de sensibilisation
octobre rose le centre médico-social du
lac de Mantes-la-Jolie organisait des
ateliers dans le but de faciliter la vie
des malades Gabriel Gontier est a
participé à une de ses séances on
regarde son reportage voilà on respire
et on expire à première vue il pourrait
s'agir d'une simple séance de relaxation
mais les soins prodigués aujourd'hui par
Valérie maillot socio-esthéticienne sont
à destination des personnes atteintes du
cancer ou en rémission afin de les
accompagner au mieux la socio-esthétique
s'est prodiguer des soins de bien-être
de confort à toute personne en fait
fragilisée par la maladie notamment ici
le cancer mais aussi par la vieillesse
le handicap encore peu connu la pratique
existe pourtant depuis
1970 alliant écoute et soins chaque
séance s'adapte aux besoins des patients
et aux spécificités des pathologies ça
m'a apporté beaucoup parce que j'ai pu
d'abord ça m'a rassurer un peu et j'ai
vu énormément de gens j'ai des
énormément de gens à Poissy parce que
c'est malheureusement c'est très mal
il y a beaucoup de formulaires il y a
beaucoup de d'associations mais c'est
très mal connu par les patients
eux-mêmes à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui cette pratique se
démocratise notamment grâce à sa prise
en charge par différents acteurs parmi
eux les dispositifs d'aide à la
coordination du ministère de la Santé
cette prise en charge est un point en
moins pour les malades après tout le
parcours de soins que j'avais un petit
peu commencé les opérations la chimio
etc j'ai découvert que en fait on avait
le droit à cinq séances de
socio-esthétiques par an pris en charge
et donc via DAC Nord
j'ai rencontré Valérie la
socio-esthéticienne qui chaque
rendez-vous m'a apporté une petite bulle
de bonheur de confort de de bien-être
dans tous ces traitements douloureux la
socio-esthétique est aujourd'hui
reconnue comme un soin à part entière
apportant réconfort et confiance en soi
des points clés pour accompagner les
malades sur le chemin de la guérison
et alors Gabriel vous avez assisté à une
de ces séances comment ça se passe oui
j'ai eu la chance de d'assister à une de
ces séances alors les séances sont plus
ou moins le même profil c'est des
séances qui durent environ une heure
c'est un mélange d'écoute et de soins
dans le but comme vous l'avez vu dans le
reportage de relâcher les zones de
tension la particularité de ces soins
c'est que la socio-esthéticienne elle
s'adapte complètement aux demandes et
aux besoins des patients on sait que les
traitements contre le cancer notamment
contre le cancer du sein sont parfois
douloureux donc tout ça c'est des choses
qui sont pris en compte pour les soins
et puis ça dépend aussi des envies de
chacun ce que beaucoup de bénéficiaires
nous ont dit en tout cas c'est que ces
séances sont très importantes pour eux
parmi tous les rendez-vous médicaux
qu'on imagine à l'hôpital ça fait partie
des rendez-vous qu'ils attendent avec
impatience et vous l'expliquez dans le
sujet c'est très important ces séances
sont prises en charge oui tout à fait
c'est ce que j'expliquais dans le
reportage dans le nord des Yvelines où
nous avons réalisé ce reportage
justement les malades ont le droit à 5
séances prises en charge par an alors
cette prise en charge elle se fait grâce
à l'association de la Ligue contre le
cancer des Yvelines et le dispositif
d'appui à la coordination c'est ce qu'on
appelle le DAC ici c'est le DAC Nord et
ce que nous expliquait les patients
c'est que c'est une véritable charge en
moins pour eux parmi tous les frais
qu'ils ont déjà
à prendre en charge de leur poche en ce
qui concerne le reste du département il
faut se rapprocher de la date Sud pour
les questions de prise en charge merci
Gabriel est-ce que Grégory Nicolas vous
connaissiez bah cette technique la
socio-esthétique
moi non plus vous connaissez pas mais
c'est effectivement un très bon procédé
très intéressant de le connaître et
savoir que c'est prise en charge aussi
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant de
le rappeler oui c'est ce que la plupart
des gens nous disent en général ils
prennent connaissance de cette pratique
quand il tombe malade mais avant peu de
gens connaissent finalement cette
pratique on change un peu du tout au
tout Nicolas je le disais au tout début
de l'émission vous allez nous présenter
une créatrice yvelinoise et je crois que
vous nous avez concocté un petit jeu
mais effectivement un petit jeu autour
de cette créatrice qui s'appelle Mélissa
sebir elle est à Richebourg elle a sa
boutique elle a ouvert sa boutique en
mars 2022 à Richebourg et je vous
propose un jeu c'était en fait cette
créatrice à particularité c'est qu'elle
est éco-responsable et récupère du
matériel du tissu pour le transformer en
vêtements et donc on va on va on va bien
l'écouter elle a des questions pour vous
on va écouter d'abord la première
question d'après vous qu'est-ce que j'ai
pu coudre dans ce couvre-lit d'après
vous voilà alors un couvre-lit un
couvre-lit vert à votre avis elle a fait
quoi avec ça
des rideaux une nappe
une robe avec on va écouter la réponse
et regardez bien
la réponse c'est cette robe trench que
vous pouvez porter pas uniquement à la
maison mais dehors aussi je vous assure
voilà
deuxième on va on va faire la deuxième
question on va voir le deuxième matériel
proposé
deuxième tissu donc c'était un rideau il
reste plus grand chose justement deviner
ce que j'ai fait avec ce rideau
voilà un rideau rose à votre avis elle a
fait quoi avec ce rideau rose peut-être
ouais une écharpe
Gabriel c'est ça allez réponse
la réponse est ce chemisier vintage
en or voilà le petit chemisier avec des
boutons en or c'est très beau en tout
cas allez dernière allez dernière
question vous pouvez vous rattraper
Grégory a un point Gabriel a un point
Mathilde c'est à votre tour de on va
écouter la question à votre avis à
partir de ce rideau qu'est-ce que j'ai
pu coudre
une jupe une jupe
c'est une jupe que vous allez d'ailleurs
pouvoir découvrir dans le reportage
et voilà donc Mélissa me tend la perche
ben on va voir ce reportage et vous
allez découvrir comment en 45 minutes et
je dis bien en 45 minutes elle a
fabriqué la jupe à partir du rideau noir
que vous venez de voir
dans ces box finalement c'est des dons
ou des rideaux que je récupère moi
et j'avais envie de vous proposer
quelque chose avec ce rideau elle n'a
pas de baguette magique mais une machine
à coudre Mélissa s'est bien est une
créatrice de mode elle fabrique des
vêtements à partir de récupération de
tissus ce jour-là elle va transformer un
rideau en jupe j'étale la matière et
quand j'ai besoin d'un patron je mets un
patron c'est lui qui va me permettre de
découper un vêtement à la bonne taille à
la bonne forme voilà c'est vraiment
l'essence même en fait du vêtement la
naissance d'une du vêtement pour cette
création pas besoin de patron là du coup
comme c'est une jupe d'hiver je vais
ajouter une doublure aussi pour
renforcer le pour ajouter un peu plus de
chaleur en fait et que finalement on
n'est pas froid en portant le vêtement
là du coup je vais passer à la partie
couture donc à la réalisation des
ourlets l'assemblage de la doublure avec
la le tissu principal et la mise en
place d'un élastique
[Musique]
en 45 minutes la jupe est terminée
autodidacte dans sa pratique la
couturière a appris toute seule elle a
développé sa propre méthode et
correspondable c'est vraiment la matière
qui va m'inspirer un vêtement donc
parfois ça va être spontané parfois il
va s'écouler plusieurs mois il y a
beaucoup de récupération parce que
finalement toutes mes chutes de tissus
sont transformées en accessoires de mode
chouchou petit sac petite pochette pour
vraiment être sur du zéro déchet
j'achète aussi des tissus qui viennent
de stock de romans donc ça veut dire que
ce sont des tissus que qui sont
entreposés dans des entrepôts et qui ont
une vocation à finir brûler ou incinérer
à Richebourg près de Houdan Mélissa
ouvert son magasin en mars 2022
l'Artisanat a commencé son activité en
2018 elle était encore salariée mais
libinoise kit son emploi en mars 2020
pour se consacrer pleinement à son
activité entrepreneuriale prouver que la
mode
l'artisanat en fait dans la mode était
en train de complètement disparaître on
en entend plus parler au profit
justement de ces gros industriels qui
produisent en surproduction dans les
usines donc je suis plus d'originalité
beaucoup de problèmes aussi de taille
mal coupée vêtements qui tournent au
lavage bref la qualité qui commence à
devenir un petit peu compliqué chemisier
manteau jupe les vêtements sont divers
la créatrice vient même de lancer une
collection pour bébé à la mode de
Mélissa
alors moi ce que je préfère je pense que
c'est le petit chemisier Gabriel est-ce
que vous avez je crois que j'ai une
préférence pour le trench notre trench
est-ce que ça vous laisserait tenter
peut-être Grégory d'acheter ça pour une
pote dulcine
j'ai bien j'ai bien aimé et je trouve
que c'est une pratique qui fait sens
aujourd'hui il y a les aussi les grandes
marques qui s'y mettent qui récupèrent
les anciens vêtements pour essayer de
les transformer mais qu'une hyvelinoise
puisse le faire à un niveau local et
qu'on puisse aussi relayer ce genre
d'initiative je pense que c'est une
bonne chose petite dernière anecdote
quand même donc elle utilise
majoritairement du tissu récupéré elle
achète un peu de tissu mais toujours
avec cette notion des co-responsabilités
et les correspondabilités va jusqu'à
même l'étiquette qui est voilà
éco-responsable voilà merci Nicolas pour
la découverte et puis pour ce petit quiz
vous nous laissez du coup la porte
ouverte pour notre partie loisir dans
cette émission c'est maintenant
[Musique]
et le cinéma attire de moins en moins de
monde entre 2021 et 2022 sur le mois de
septembre la fréquentation est en baisse
de 20 %. alors le covid et les
plateformes vidéo sont passées par là
mais aussi la hausse du pouvoir d'achat
et à ce sujet Patrice carmouz recevait
Luc Bocan le directeur de cineset à
Élancourt on va faire le point
maintenant sur la crise de fréquentation
du cinéma avec Luc boccan bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur du cn7
d'Élancourt alors j'ai regardé les
chiffres c'est quand même assez
dramatique puisque on dit que la
fréquentation du cinéma est la plus
basse depuis 40 ans c'est ça c'est ça
exactement alors souvent on dit voilà il
y a deux grands facteurs les gens ont
perdu avec le covid l'habitude d'aller
au cinéma c'est une première chose et le
deuxième facteur c'est l'arrivée des
plateformes qui fait que bon chez soi et
on a on a pratiquement ce qu'on pourrait
avoir quand on va au cinéma est-ce que
c'est votre votre analyse
est-ce que c'est la seule année alors
moi je reprendrai les les deux facteurs
que vous venez dénoncer je suis
absolument d'accord effectivement les
plateformes ne nous ont pas fait du bien
du tout surtout que il faut rapprocher
ça je pense du problème peut-être aussi
du prix des places qui est quand même
devenu relativement élevé
une famille de 4 personnes et voilà
c'est une plateforme sujet bien compris
c'est à peu près 9 10 euros par mois
c'est 10 11 euros est-ce que c'est pas
un petit peu trop cher je sais que
certains militent pour ce soir encore un
petit peu plus cher en allant vers le
premier etc moi c'est pas mon avis mais
bon les avis sont partagés je pense
aussi que les plateformes pour pour en
dire de mots très rapidement
draine aussi tous les scénaristes c'est
à dire qu'il on monte on manque de
scénariste dans le cinéma et ça se voit
ça se sent là je regarde un petit peu ce
qui sort l'année prochaine les trois
mousquetaires vous voyez encore une
version des Trois Mousquetaires alors
j'espère qu'elle est réussie il y a
Vincent Cassel
on en a quand même vu un certain nombre
déjà donc donc il y a ça je pense aussi
qu'il y a un problème d'offre de films
c'est-à-dire que oui je crois que
de ce changement d'habitude d'ailleurs
j'ai regardé moi aussi enfin c'est le
monde a fait un gros papier là-dessus
j'ai regardé les chiffres Roomba la
ville le film de Dubos qui a fait 20000
ans très papa pas terrible il y a une
canaille avec José Garcia et François
Cluzet qui est absolument
de 60 000 entre je crois enfin bon une
catastrophe catastrophe et en même temps
alors ça c'est le côté catastrophe et
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a des films
comme la nuit du 12 qui sont des films
d'auteurs plutôt de ou revoir Paris qui
ont bien marché quoi absolument non mais
c'est vrai que il y a il y a un public
pour la recette de toute façon qui est
fort donc dans nos salles mais c'est
vrai qu'on manque de locomotive même moi
je suis très content que la nuit du 12
ait trouvé son public parce qu'en plus
il est sorti très bon film sorti en
plein milieu d'été c'était quand même un
sacré Paris pour Dominique Moll et son
équipe de sortir des films
je me souviens de son premier film c'est
sorti en 15 août c'est vrai et avait
fait un succès absolument et donc là on
a eu aussi pour prendre le contre-pied
on va dire du film de Dominique molk
personnellement j'ai beaucoup aimé Top
Gun Maverick qui a été un gros succès
quand même mais qui à mon sens n'a pas
eu le succès qu'il aurait dû avoir si on
n'avait pas ce problème de fréquentation
des salles je sais plus à combien il a
terminé sa carrière mais il aurait dû
faire je pense plus et là c'est vrai
qu'on manque de locomotive qu'on appelle
dans le jargon du métier les
blockbusters
et puis qui attire aussi les gens et qui
vont parfois voir les autres films
exactement voilà et donc là on manque de
blockbusters et les Américains ont
beaucoup beaucoup c'est surtout des
films américains qui ont beaucoup été
reportés sur 2023 et je pense parce que
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure pour
préparer un petit peu notre rencontre ce
qui sort sur le premier semestre 2023 il
y a du lourd non il y a pas vraiment il
faut attendre il faut attendre mission
impossible au mois de juillet qui est
vraiment un gros blockbuster Tom Cruise
etc et puis après on sait pas trop ce
qui se passe sur la deuxième sur le
deuxième semestre de l'année 2023
j'espère que les films vont arriver
parce qu'on a besoin et donc dans les
semaines qui viennent là il y a deux
trois choses que vous voyez qu'il faut
attirer je pense que il y a je pense que
tout n'est pas perdu loin de là il y a
mascarade qui sort le film de Nicolas
Bedos qui est quand même très attendu il
fait deux excellents films déjà
exactement il y a Black Panther là je
parlais de blockbuster Black Panther est
un blockbusters qui sort bientôt il y a
couleur de l'incendie moi j'y crois
beaucoup parce que
voilà de Pierre Lemaître comme vous le
savez c'est le bouquin est tellement
fort tellement beau formidable j'espère
que le film sera à la hauteur on se
souvient du premier opus de Dupontel qui
était quand même très réussi dans le
genre de ponthelles au revoir là-haut
formidable et là c'est donc c'est un
autre un autre style Léa Drucker Benoît
Poel
ça peut être pas mal et puis bien sûr je
ne peux pas oublier avatar
deuxième opus qui sort le 14 décembre en
3D dans un premier temps etc on espère
tous on croise les doigts on n'est pas
trop pessimiste de toute façon moi je
reste optimiste parce que je pense que
la salle alors c'est c'est pas forcément
facile en ce moment de dire ça mais la
salle est irremplaçable la salle était
remplaçable un écran je vois par exemple
aussi les 7 notre plus petite salle
l'écran fait 6 mètres 50
merci beaucoup
donc on croise les doigts pour que ça
marche aussi des locaux et merci
beaucoup merci à vous et alors autour du
plateau je me demande est-ce que bah
Vous vous allez toujours au cinéma
Gabriel ben j'avais fait une longue
pause mais la SAC depuis la rentrée j'y
suis allée trois fois d'affilée là je
trouve qu'il y a des très bon films qui
sont sortis
peut-être des idées aussi de films que
vous avez envie de voir Grégory très
prochainement il y a forcément le
deuxième volet d'Avatar qui va arriver
je pense que voilà c'est le film que
j'attends avec impatience sur cette
année 2022 moi j'y allais beaucoup avant
avant la crise sanitaire quasiment deux
à trois fois par semaine j'avais même un
abonnement dans une salle de cinéma et
c'est vrai que depuis et l'émergence
petit à petit des plateformes de vidéos
c'est plus facile de rester chez soi
plus facile plus confortable on va dire
même si je trouve que le film au cinéma
ça a quand même une saveur différente
d'être installée dans son petit fauteuil
le petit pop-corn aussi de temps en
temps sans gêner le voisin parce que ça
peut être aussi vite difficile bah on le
retrouve pas ce côté un peu authentique
quand on est dans son canapé
Nicolas vous vous êtes prochainement je
pense que je vais aller voir le jouet
avec un yvelinois qu'on connaît tous
avec Jamel Debbouze voilà donc ça c'est
prévu prochainement
on va parler du château de Dampierre
maintenant les bâches sont tombées en
juillet dernier révélant ainsi les
nouvelles façades du château mais il
reste encore quelques travaux à faire
notamment la restauration des murs et
des deux pavillons de la garde à
l'entrée le reportage de Julien Leroy
pierre qui ont quasiment achevé c'est ça
la pose des balustrad une nouvelle
jeunesse pour le château de Dampierre
les nouvelles façades du monument ont
été révélées au public en juillet
dernier remplacement des briques de la
toiture nouvel enduit et bois de
charpente renouvelée là la seule coup et
bien les couleurs de Dampierre
reviennent l'ocre la brique tout ça
resplendit et tout ça c'était refait
admirablement par tous les compagnons le
propriétaire Monsieur Mullier même n'en
revient pas
je vais répéter ces mots qui dit en fait
mon château est joli il y avait pas
imaginé que ce château était si joli
parce que quand il avait acheté
évidemment il était dégradé près de 300
personnes onteurées depuis 2020 à
l'embellissement du château un des plus
gros chantiers privés sur un monument
historique ouvert au public en France
les ouvriers peaufinés actuellement les
derniers détails sur la base des murs on
remet des petits caillots
et bien on a engagé des travaux sur les
pavillons d'entrée les pavillons
d'entrée ce sont les pavillons qui sont
au bord de la route à l'heure actuelle
ils sont bâchés par ces énormes bâches
qui couvrent ces pavillons on va refaire
les couvertures les charpentes les
menuiseries les et tout ce qui est
maçonnerie les rénovations intérieures
du château débuteront cours en 2023
après la mise aux normes du réseau des
cynismement d'eau et d'électricité sur
ce site classé monument historique une
étude doit être menée au préalable par
des archéologues avant les raccordements
la Direction Régionale des Affaires
Culturelles demande et oblige à ce qu'il
y aide et des fouilles archéologiques
puisque ces travaux par définition vont
être destructeurs et donc les
archéologues viennent en amont des
travaux ou alors accompagnent les
travaux pour enregistrer l'information
archéologique contenue dans sous-sol si
l'intérieur du château ne sera
accessible que début 2025 le jardin de
90 hectares reste cependant ouvert au
public pour en profiter il faudra avant
la fermeture annuelle le 6 novembre
prochain
Pascal Thévard vient de nous rejoindre
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir alors on l'a
vu dans le sujet vous êtes le directeur
général du domaine de Dampierre en
Yvelines alors première question déjà
qu'est-ce que ça fait de voir un peu à
les premiers résultats après 2 ans de
travaux
ont permis de mener de grands un grand
manifeste en tout cas sur ce chantier et
c'était vraiment la grosse surprise
quand on a fait tomber la bâche qui
protégeait cette ce chantier la seule
coup on a vu ses couleurs apparaître
qu'on avait oublié parce que parce que
le château était précédemment dégradé et
qu'il s'était affaidi et que pendant le
chantier on avait mis une énorme bâche
qui reprenait le dessin du 17e siècle et
on avait dans la tête encore le dessin
du 17e et là on a redécouvert ce château
restauré et ça a été vraiment comme dit
d'ailleurs le propriétaire c'est mouvant
c'est émouvant et c'est joli c'est joli
parce qu'en fait le château évidemment
il est très très prenant il est énorme
enfin il est lourd de passer et il est
en termes de culture c'est aussi très
important et là en fait et bien on voit
aussi l'aspect esthétique et l'aspect
esthétique ça fait plaisir à voir et
d'ailleurs d'aspect esthétique et ça
veut dire que si on a enlevé les
bassines dans le château donc du coup
j'ai aussi quelque part une réjouissance
et alors ça samedi vous allez pouvoir
organiser la nuit des châteaux ce sera
samedi 22 octobre c'est aussi du coup
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
ou de redécouvrir le domaine de
Dampierre exactement de vous en profiter
de de nous inscrire depuis quatre ans
dans une manifestation nationale qui
s'appelle la nuit des châteaux et dans
le cadre de cette manifestation cette
année nous avons voulu mettre à
l'honneur évidemment une façade
emblématique du château qui est celle du
côté du jardin et donc nous allons nous
avons nous allons pardon projeter un
mapping un mapping géant parce qu'en
fait ce château c'est vraiment énorme
comme surface et donc c'est un mapping
géant qui me mobilise beaucoup de moyens
techniques et pour cet événement et bien
on a voulu offrir au public la
possibilité de s'évader
cette soirée dans un monde chimérique
puisque les chimères sont très
importantes à Dampierre dans l'histoire
de Dampierre depuis le 17e siècle et
donc voilà on a fait cette évocation
chimérique de cette façade restaurée en
mettant tout à la fois à l'honneur les
compagnons qui ont parallèle de cette
façade et bien comme d'habitude il y a
des lampions tout autour de l'étang
parlons des bougies tout autour de
l'étang on a 1500 bougies qui vont être
installés et puis les gens se promènent
avec des lampions donc vraiment quelque
chose vraiment de très patrimonial
puisqu'on va découvrir cette façade
restaurée cette façade mise en lumière
et puis la découverte du site évidemment
vous attendez beaucoup de monde
peut-être
écoutez le contexte actuel est un peu
difficile à estimer l'année dernière
nous avions fait 3000 personnes qui est
déjà très très bien parce que 3000
personnes a absorbé dans nos petites
structures d'accueil c'est beaucoup de
travail les équipes sont vraiment
vraiment
sollicités et je les en remercie mais on
arrive à relever le défi et trouver une
personne ce serait formidable seulement
avec le pénurie d'essence maintenant
tout se remet en place on va voir je
crois que la météo voilà
de voir enfin voir si la météo est bonne
Grégory pour les habitués des jardins du
domaine de Dampierre qu'est-ce qui
pourrait est-ce que on peut redécouvrir
le domaine à la nuit tombée est-ce qu'il
y a des choses différentes à observer
évidemment pour les habitués il y a tous
les ans une de quelque chose de
différent cette année évidemment le
mapping géant qui mobilise beaucoup de
moyens et une surprise dans sur les
temps une surprise sur les temps ou une
évocation très artistique par une jeune
artiste Marie-France turbo de des chats
loupes qui étaient sur sur cet étang au
18e siècle et bien elle a fait une
interprétation comme l'année dernière
d'ailleurs c'est la même qui avait fait
ses tours ces cubes rouges et bien là
c'est pour cette soirée là je dis pas
plus mais voilà il faut venir sur place
pour le découvrir dessus volontairement
mais on a fait des tests et c'est
superbe à qui est-ce que ça s'adresse
est-ce que c'est pour tout le monde
public complètement familial convivial
il y a une musique d'ambiance qui anime
mapping c'est vraiment nous ce qu'on
veut c'est que les gens prennent du
plaisir tout de zéro on n'est pas un peu
trop jeune pour voir évidemment à zéro
mais en tout cas de deux à
99 ans ou plus non vraiment c'est on
fait tout pour accueillir le public et
qui découvre ou redécouvre cette façade
restaurer et ce château évidemment qu'on
met tous en avant Nicolas j'ai une
question parce que je me rappelle la
première fois que vous êtes venu sur ce
plateau quand vous arriviez dans les
Yvelines parce que vous étiez à Chambord
vous êtes toujours d'ailleurs hein
mais vous êtes vous êtes des
allers-retours et vous étiez avant
directeur du château de Chambord je me
rappelle de du jour où vous êtes venus
pour la première fois mauvaise plateau
quel bilan vous faites depuis votre
arrivée au château de Dampierre alors un
bilan très enthousiaste parce que je
rappelle quand je quand l'équipe elle
s'est mise en place quand je suis arrivé
dans Pierre avait été effacé des
circuits touristiques alors on va on a
pas remis en place avec les bus et
autres parce que pour l'instant c'est
les travaux mais en tout cas il y a un
public qui répond ce que j'avais
présager et à quel point c'est que on a
commencé la première année avec 20000
visiteurs et en trois ans on est arrivé
à 45000 l'année dernière en visiteur
donc ça veut dire que on a vraiment un
public qui est en attente et qu'on offre
si possible des animations qui
permettent au public de découvrir sous
différentes différents regards en tout
cas ce patrimoine on a fait les plaisirs
de Dampierre avec les costumes qui
évoquent la visite de Louis XVIIIe
siècle mais par exemple on fait aussi
les balles de Dampierre l'art de
l'attelage l'art de Hippo Hippo et
automobile on le commet en avant on
essaie à chaque fois de trouver des
points de de développement et le public
répond et je vois d'ailleurs la reprise
elle fait point c'est que vous aussi
vous êtes fidèle vous m'invitez à
nouveau quatre ans après et d'autres
médias et bien font aussi appel à nous
en disant mais voilà vous commencez à
vous développer et donc voilà il y a une
belle une belle synergie qui est mise en
place et avec les partenaires aussi
locaux et territoriaux importants
évidemment le conseil régional qui nous
aide le Conseil départemental également
enfin vraiment tout le monde nous aide à
vraiment créer cette dynamique suivie
quand je vous ai reçu vous aviez été
nommé tout récemment directeur général
du domaine de Dampierre j'avais fait des
recherches et j'ai dit tomber d'abord
sur le domaine de Dampierre en Guyonne
c'était difficile de trouver des
informations sur le domaine de denfermé
donc vous avez placé dans pierre en
Yvelines sur la carte de France alors
attends
on a replacé la carte sur sur dans les
Yvelines mais c'est incroyable de voir
les archives on a pu retrouver en
recherchant chez les bouquinistes ou
même dans les archives du château que
Dampierre était une destination mais la
première destination en Île-de-France
jusque dans les années en monument privé
vaut le vicomte par exemple on en
parlait pas dans les années 80 et dans
pierre s'était passé et à tel point
alors j'étais un peu long mais une
anecdote on a on a découvert une carte
des années 30 qui localise Paris dans
son environnement et bien quand il
n'apparaît pas chantilly n'apparaît pas
Rambouillet n'apparaît pas Versailles
oui vous le vivez contre nous et il y a
Dampierre d'accord parce que ça fait
partie des monuments que les gens
visitaient et l'histoire a fait que
d'autres monuments voilà ont émergé et
que Dampierre c'est un peu effacé du
territoire et nous on est là non pas
pour faire du chiffre de fréquentation
mais au moins pour valoriser ce
patrimoine et installer à terme là dans
dans le reportage je le dis à partir de
de l'année prochaine on commence les
travaux sur les jardins ont commencé
travaux à l'intérieur pour installer la
collection de d'œuvres d'art du
propriétaire vraiment on est sur une
dynamique patrimoniale forte
qui vous attendent alors je parle sous
votre contrôle parce qu'elle démarre
l'ouverture des portes pour la nuit du
château se fera à 18h pour les mises en
lumière et jusqu'à la nuit tombée donc
pour la nuit tombée et ça se terminera à
22h c'est bien ça c'est la fermeture des
portes mais les gens peuvent partir
ensuite 23h il y a pas de souci d'accord
donc vous êtes parfaitement bien
renseigné et donc l'entrée est gratuite
pour les moins de 6 ans sinon le billet
est à 15 euros ou 10 euros pour pour le
tarif réduit et donc bah si vous êtes
intéressé vous pouvez vous munir d'un
billet sur le site internet de Dampierre
merci
Gabriel vous nous avez trouvé d'autres
idées de sortie mais c'est plutôt pour
les vacances de la Toussaint cette
fois-ci est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus et oui c'est ça Mathilde les
vacances de la Toussaint approche à
grand page vous êtes donc préparé une
petite sélection des sorties à découvrir
seul en famille ou entre amis c'est
comme vous voulez et qui dit vacances de
la Toussaint dit Halloween oui comme
chaque année franchement miniature se
met aux couleurs d'Halloween les 117
monuments du parc risque de se voir
envahir sous peu de toiles d'araignées
de squelettes ou encore de bien d'autres
curiosités au programme également un jeu
de piste une distribution de bonbons et
plein d'autres surprises de quoi ravir
les petits et les grands et en parlant
de jeux de Pise vous nous en avez trouvé
un mais moins effrayant cette fois-ci
oui celui-là c'est un jeu de piste
historique et en extérieur au cœur des
jardins du château de Versailles seules
contraintes pour participer être au
minimum 2 vous trouverez quelqu'un dans
cette pièce je pense et c'est à
découvrir jusqu'au 31 octobre et pour
ceux qui préfèrent les activités en
intérieur vous allez nous parler de deux
musées oui deux sites ont retenus mon
attention déjà le Musée du Jouet de
Poissy alors on le connaît l'endroit est
idéal pour vous replonger dans l'univers
de l'enfance ce que l'on sait moins et
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'au
travers de l'exposition vous découvrirez
l'histoire du jouet mais aussi celle des
matériaux des modes de production et de
diffusion le musée vous apprend
également sur la place de l'enfant dans
la société et du jouet dans son
éducation et dans son épanouissement
psychomoteur de quoi intéresser les
enfants mais aussi les parents
exactement et le second musée que j'ai
choisi est un peu différent cette fois
il s'agit du musée d'archéologie
nationale alors il a été créé en 1862 le
musée est consacré à l'archéologie comme
son comme son nom l'indique pardon de la
France mais c'est également un voyage
dans le temps mais aussi au travers des
différents continents ce qui est
intéressant ici Mathilde de c'est la
comparaison qui est faite entre les
époques et les lieux et tout ça dans un
lieu d'exception le château de
Saint-Germain la dernière activité c'est
une activité gourmande oui et je sais
que ça va en intéresser un certain
nombre de surfaces
le cuisinière du roi propose des
ateliers de cuisine car il est Jérôme
donne des ateliers cuisine et
pâtisseries alors pour les entreprises
les familles mais aussi les enfants
alors un conseil pensez à réserver votre
créneau surtout pendant les vacances de
la Toussaint et bien merci avec Gabriel
pour toutes ces idées est-ce que vous
avez une préférence dans tout ça petite
prise préférence pour l'atelier cuisine
je pense Pascal tevermine préférence
si j'avais du temps parce que nous on a
aussi beaucoup d'activités et
d'animations liées aux couleurs de
l'automne et d'Halloween à Dampierre
mais si j'avais du temps c'est
Saint-Germain-en-Laye évidemment
archéologiques c'est magnifique et vous
Nicolas
je pense que certains ont prévu leur
déguisements pour Halloween j'ai un
déguisement quelque part chez moi
faudrait que je ressorte Grégory
l'atelier fusil mais après pour la
dégustation du coup
sinon halloween halloween le classique
et on prévoit toujours son petit
déguisement pour Halloween c'est bientôt
la fin de cette émission
de ceux qui tend de demain
[Musique]
prévoyez quelques averses demain matin
du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie et de
Versailles à Houdan et Rambouillet vous
devriez avoir un temps sec avec de
belles éclaircies au niveau des
températures il fera toujours très doux
avec 16 degrés en moyenne vendredi
après-midi le soleil sera présent sur
toutes les Yvelines avec des
températures très agréables il fera 20
degrés à aux dents à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et 19 degrés à Rambouillet
et Gabriel vous êtes un peu notre
journaliste week-end alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter la météo de
ce week-end
ensoleillé qui nous attend alors samedi
les températures seront comprises en
moyenne entre 11 et 13 degrés le matin
l'après-midi il fera 19 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet et la
température attendent atteindra jusqu'à
20 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie même
scénario pour dimanche avec des
températures comprises en moyenne entre
12 et 13 degrés le matin et 21 degrés
l'après-midi sur l'ensemble du
département
et là je vois que ça se confirme pour
que ça va être super merci beaucoup
Gabriel un petit tour maintenant sur les
prévisions au niveau des routes
peut-être avec les vacances de la
Toussaint qui approche Grégory début des
vacances de la Toussaint alors s'il vous
reste un peu d'essence dans le réservoir
peut-être vous apprêtez-vous à partir et
à prendre la route demain soir pour ce
début des congés vendredi Bison Futé
voit orange sans aider pas en
Île-de-France il est conseillé d'éviter
de quitter la région entre 14h et 21h la
couleur qui reste à l'orange dans le
sens des départs également samedi pour
ne pas vous retrouver dans les bouchons
il est conseillé de partir avant 9h en
revanche c'est vers dimanche dans les
deux sens de circulation merci beaucoup
Grégory et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous tous en plateau
d'avoir été présent je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez bien
soin de vous
[Musique]